here's a story because of the high
numbers of coronavirus cases in the u.s
americans are banned from traveling to
most countries yeah
but guess what our newest sponsor
has a solution
are you an american who loves to
vacation
unfortunately the news these days only
tells you places
you can't go americans are barred from
entering europe starting july 1st well
here at can go travel
we focus on the places you can go
plenty of places still want your
hard-earned american greenbacks
for instance yemen as in yeah man
major airlines still flies there yeah
yemen is beautiful this time of year
every night rebel and government forces
face off
in a fireworks game show called is that
a missile
hint the answer is always yes is the
middle east not your thing
well don't worry oh jesus well
don't worry not every country in europe
hates
america that's right russia
the land of vodka beets and 30 year olds
who look 75
watch out for falling doctors
but if you're anything like me summer
isn't summer
without some latin in your america
mexico is hardening
its border against americans well mexico
might be
tieme akoved afraid of koved
but you know who isn't brazil that's
right
the land of hard bodies hot bodies and
antibodies
look at those stats while pessimists
might call this class half empty
i call it half full of people who have
recovered from covet and are no longer
contagious hopefully
trust me in brazil the only thing you
have to worry about getting
is mugged so cheer up america
plenty of countries still want us all
for good only if you're seeing this ad
in july no guarantees during the second
wave of quran virus coming in october